>>> CALL IT CLEVER, CALL IT
REVERSE PSYCHOLOGY, WHATEVER YOU
CALL IT, THE MESSAGE MAY BE
GETTING THROUGH TO THE
UNVACCINATED.
HAVE YOU SEEN THIS YET?
A DIGITAL BILLBOARD DRIVING
AROUND CHARLOTTE WITH THIS
MESSAGE.
DON'T GET VACCINATED.
AND THEN THERE'S A LINK TO
WILMORE FUNERAL HOME.
BUT HERE'S THE THING.
WILMORE ISN'T ACTUALLY A FUNERAL
HOME, AND WHEN YOU VISIT THE
WEBSITE, THIS IS THE MESSAGE YOU
SEE.
GET VACCINATED NOW WITH A LINK
TO AN AREA URGENT CARE WHERE YOU
CAN MAKE A VACCINE APPOINTMENT.
ALL OF THIS, THE CREATIVE BRAIN
CHILD OF A LOCAL AD AGENCY, MOON
OAKLEY AND THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR
AND PRESIDENT OF THAT AGENCY,
DAVID OAKLEY, JOINS US NOW.
DAVID, THIS IS A PRETTY CREATIVE
IDEA.
IT'S GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
TALKING, THAT'S FOR SURE.
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH THE
IDEA, AND WHAT WAS YOUR GOAL?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, ANA,
THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON TODAY.
I'M VERY PROUD OF THE WORK THAT
OUR TEAM HAS COME UP WITH.
THEY DID A GREAT JOB ON IT.
YEAH.
>> SO, HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH
THIS IDEA?
WHAT WAS THE GOAL?
>> WELL, OUR WHOLE GOAL WAS WE
NOTICED HOW THE VACCINATION RATE
HAD REALLY FLATTENED IN NORTH
CAROLINA AND WE WERE HAVING A
CREATIVE MEETING ABOUT THREE
WEEKS AGO AND WE DECIDED THAT
MAYBE WE SHOULD TAKE THIS ON AS
A PASSION PROJECT.
WE ARE ALL VACCINATED AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WE'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT THAT MAYBE
TRADITIONAL MESSAGING LIKE, GET
THE SHOT, GET VACCINATED REALLY
WEREN'T MOVING THE NEEDLE, NO
PUN INTENDED.
BUT WE -- SO, WE DECIDED THAT,
LIKE, WHO'S REALLY BENEFITTING
FROM ALL THESE PEOPLE THAT
AREN'T GETTING VACCINATED?
WHAT BUSINESSES ARE DOING WELL
BECAUSE OF IT?
AND I THINK MARY GROSS SAID,
WOW, WHAT ABOUT A FUNERAL HOME?
WE STARTED LAUGHING ABOUT IT AND
THEN WE SAID, THAT'S RIGHT, THEY
WOULDN'T WANT YOU TO GET
VACCINATED BECAUSE IT'S GOOD FOR
THEIR BUSINESS, SO THAT'S HOW
THE IDEA WAS BORN, AND OVER A
COUPLE OF DAYS, WE DECIDED TO DO
IT AS A MOBILE BILLBOARD, AND
DEBUT IT DURING THE CAROLINA
PANTHERS-SAINTS GAME ON SUNDAY.
>> I THINK EVERYBODY'S
WONDERING, DID IT WORK?
HERE'S WHAT WE'VE DISCOVERED.
STAR MED, THE URGENT MEDICAL
CARE FACILITY TELLS US THEY HAVE
SEEN A 22% INCREASE IN VACCINE
APPOINTMENT REGISTRATIONS THIS
WEEK COMPARED TO LAST WEEK.
AND THAT THIS IS AT A TIME WHEN
NATIONALLY, THE VACCINE RATES
ARE DECLINING.
SO, WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO
THAT?
>> WELL, THAT MAKES ME REALLY
HAPPY.
WHEN WE WENT INTO IT, OUR GOAL
WAS, IF WE CAN GET ONE PERSON
VACCINATED BECAUSE OF THIS
MESSAGE, IT'S A TOTAL SUCCESS.
JUST ONE PERSON.
SO, TO HEAR THAT THEY HAD A 22%
INCREASE SO FAR IS -- I'M VERY
PROUD OF THAT AND HAPPY, AND
HOPEFULLY IT WILL CONTINUE
TRENDING IN THAT DIRECTION.
>> IT'S KIND OF AN EDGY IDEA,
RIGHT?
HAS THERE BEEN ANY BACKLASH TO
YOUR AD?
>> WELL, IT'S KIND OF FUNNY.
THE ARC OF WHEN YOU SEE IT.
IT'S SO STARK TO SEE A MESSAGE
THAT ACTUALLY IS SO BLATANT TO
SAY, DON'T GET VACCINATED, AND
AT FIRST YOU THINK IT'S FROM AN
ANTI-VAXXER GROUP AND YOU READ A
LITTLE FARTHER AND YOU'RE LIKE,
WHAT?
IT'S FROM A FUNERAL HOME?
HUH?
WE'VE GOTTEN A LITTLE FEEDBACK.
WE'VE GOTTEN A COUPLE OF, SHALL
I SAY, CRAZY PEOPLE CALLING
BOONE OAKLEY ABOUT IT, BUT OTHER
THAN THAT, I'M VERY HAPPY WITH
THE RESULT.
>> SO, IF IT'S A SUCCESS, AND
GIVEN, JUST UNDER 49% OF
RESIDENTS ARE FULLY VACCINATED
IN NORTH CAROLINA, ARE YOU
THINKING MAYBE DOING A TAKE TWO
OR HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT
EXPANDING IT TO OTHER CITIES OR
STATEWIDE?
>> IT'S FUNNY YOU ASK, ANA,
BECAUSE WE HAVE HAD QUESTIONS
ALL MORNING FROM DIFFERENT
CITIES ABOUT DIFFERENT FOOTBALL
EVENTS, DIFFERENT THINGS
HAPPENING IN THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS AND ASKING IF WE COULD
BRING THE TRUCK BACK OUT AND
IT'S SOMETHING WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT DOING RIGHT NOW.
>> WELL, KEEP US POSTED.
DAVID OAKLEY, APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS AND THANKS FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO SHARE WITH US TODAY.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO GET TO BE
HERE WITH YOU, AND GET THE SHOT,
EVERYBODY.
DO IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
JUST DO